[Musique]
la journée commence bien avant l'eau
pour le commandant sébastien bach xac il
va décoller et atterrir à cinq reprises
au cours des six prochaines heures nous
ferons avec lui des sceaux peu centre
des aéroports régionaux du québec
destination wabush près de fermont
à bord de l'avion une quinzaine de
personnes quelques unes rentrer à la
maison et la plupart se dirige vers le
travail
on s'est retrouvé à wabush pour la mi
2009 à québec fois la fibre optique tout
est élu les réparations scintillante
elle près ce moment de travailleurs
on se déplacer quand différentes régions
après ce moment de grâce à l'écran tron
comme sept-îles et wabush est ce qu on
voit aussi de plus en plus signifiante
elle d'affaires
c'est quelque part à l'est de québec on
aperçoit les premiers rayons de soleil
le moment préféré du pilote pour
commencer sa longue journée de travail
on a des avions sans auto pilot
donc on voit le
soit commandant le co pilote qui vole en
tout temps l'avion et puis c'est un type
d'aviation c'est ça ou est ce qu'on
prend un peu plus de décision là dans le
cockpit par l'équipage de
le bureau à berlin
les vols comme celui ci transporte plus
de 800 mille passagers chaque année
entre les quelque 140 aéroports
régionaux du québec
ils permettent de couvrir des distances
considérables en voiture à partir de
montréal
il faut compter 16 heures pour se rendre
affirmant 10 heures vers gaspé et plus
de 7h30 pour rouyn noranda
je
là où la route ne seront pas l'avion
contribuer à briser l' isolement
c'est ce qui a permis à cette mère et à
son fils qui vivent à blanc-sablon de
visiter leur famille en gaspésie je me
sens pas loin je pense que c'est grâce à
l'avion les jeux récents
même si
ça brasse beaucoup
la viande humaine
regard de la famille
[Musique]
dernier arrêt avant wabush sept-îles qui
est appelé à devenir un carrefour de
plus en plus important avec la reprise
minière les emplois c'est ainsi qu'a
commencé à la hausse avec les sikhs mini
donc des cycles de cinq à dix ans le
malheureux a les cinq dernières années
ont été plutôt difficiles mais on voit
depuis le début de 2007 une reprise nous
dans nos chiffres
ce qu'on voit ses volumes en
augmentation d'environ 25 à 30%
[Musique]
un ravitaillement plus tard l'avion
plaît à craquer reprend les airs varois
bush au dessus des nuages quelques
passages et partagent leur histoire
plusieurs de nos compagnons de vols
connaissent par coeur la route désert
entre le sud où ils résident de la
moitié du temps et le nord où ils
travaillent
brent hayden
de josé que le voisin de crédit lié moi
j'attends c'est un mode de vie s'est
défaussé rats ils font ce procès
beaucoup à cause des températures mais
nos bons choix on est arrivé à howard
aus 6 mois et 26 degrés au thermomètre
et c'est ici que la majorité des
passagers sont descendus on a eu
beaucoup de on en profite pour aller à
la rencontre du maire de fermont parce
que c'est là que se dirige une grande
partie des travailleurs ont des quand
même chanceux parce que les minières ont
apporté un important volume de passagers
ça fait en sorte que les compagnies ont
enfin plusieurs heures de vol la
différence il fallait en za de la
journée
mais ce qui empêche davantage de
citoyens de fermont de prendre l'avion
c'est le cri des billets environ 1000 $
pour une aller retour vers montréal
je pense qu'il ya du travail à faire
pour améliorer la disponibilité c'est
vraiment d'adder c'est à dire parce que
lorsque tu vois maintenant une famille
qui habite avec deux enfants 104
personnes veulent quitter la région si
ces pratiques mais tout à 4 milles à
l'heure
[Musique]
cinquième et dernier décollage du jour
pour sébastien bach diack qui va
terminer sa journée de travail à mont
joli
là aussi on veut profiter de la relance
minière ça fait en sorte que ces
travailleurs là en utilisant fly in fly
out revienne dans la région de façon
régulière et finalement conservent leurs
maisons dans les endroits dans lesquels
ils sont et puisse continuer à alimenter
le commerce et l'industrie dans notre
région
mais pour jouer leur rôle dans le
développement économique les aéroports
régionaux doivent investir dans leurs
infrastructures et les besoins sont
grands
400 millions de dollars d'ici cinq ans
selon une étude commandée par l'union
des municipalités du québec
sébastien bach d'isaac navigue donc dans
un environnement appelé à changer et à
travers les turbulences sa passion reste
intacte
[Musique]